我們用MACD找到快速派發的一個趨勢
然後呢訂單塊跟FBG
等待回補的時候
我們選擇一個位置去進場
那進場後大家也發現
這一張單我們就是順著看通的方向打下來
下跌後的回調不過0.0.5延續下跌
而且回補FBG我們可以快速的達到什麼
下方流動性的位置
那這一
有時候你明明看對方向
卻總是慢一步的進場
爆發段沒辦法遲到
回踩點又抓不準
那我今天要教你一個
在短線交易進場的順勢打法
它是搭配我們的指標之王MACD
用MACD抓到啟動訊號
加上FBG找出進場位置
那幫你在1分K裡面
搶下每一段行情的爆發點
賺錢有門到交易最可靠
大家晚安
蛋仔來了
這是一個會讓你投資
越來越有錢的頻道
好那MACD是什麼
那它怎麼抓住爆發呢
好我們快速的帶過簡單講一下
MACD由兩條線所組成
所謂的快線和慢線
那大多數使用MACD的設定通常是
快線12慢線26
好但是因為我們打短線1分K
我們把參數改為8215
好那這時候打開MACD指標
大家可以看到常見的快線長度設定是12
我們改為8
那慢線長度改為21
信號平滑度我們改為5
好那這就是我們短線MACD更為靈敏
更能抓到趨勢派發點的一個參數設定
我們要觀察什麼重點呢
來這1分K啊
我們來找到什麼
多頭準備派發的時候
MACD線穿過信號線
多頭啟動信號好不好
黃金交叉
那同樣的就是俗稱的什麼
死亡交叉
空頭信號的啟動
那我們去找柱狀體放大
然後他去翻紅翻綠的時候
價格可能打快速的什麼派發那MACD是順勢派發的起爆點的提醒器價格快速的拉漲下跌後的強力上漲通常我們會找到一個訂單塊然後我們去看到MACD快線上穿慢線的時候
好這時候快速拉漲
而當價格緩解回踩FBG的時候
有機會我們在這邊做二浪推升的進場
去抓到下一個波段
那MACD金石插會看了後
我們還要搭配什麼
FBG精準化入場好不好
所以剛剛上面講的嘛
我們找到了起漲點 快速的向上拉
回補三連跌三連漲FBG的時候
找到拐點的時候進場
好 那操作邏輯大家來記一下
第一個先找到金石差的出現
而且行情有明顯的改變
向上或是向下的慣性
最好是下跌後的強力上漲
或是上漲後的強力下跌
好 同時觀察價格有沒有留下
失衡區的缺口
如果缺口不補直接放量突破的話
我們在試情況決定要不要追單
但我們待會來找一個
回補缺口進場的例子
好那以FBG邊緣回踩
有回踩
等待要的
如果要做多看漲炫耀出現
做空看跌炫耀出現
那要留意拐頭
完成延續走勢的時候
在進場勝率會比較高
好那進場時機呢
順勢追價單
有可能他直接往下跌
沒有出現FBG的回踩
那小昌進場
那比較穩的呢
就是等待回踩
快速下跌後的回踩的第二浪
我們選擇進場
還可以搭配我們直播間長講的
斐波納奇確定0.5的位置
沒有被改變
而是做延續走勢好不好
所以MACD只決定行期什麼時候爆發
我們在1分可以找到爆發段的時候
我們用FBG去決定在哪裡進場
有好的進場點位
相信也會有好的盈虧比
相信你今天學會這一套之後
在短線上一定會有更好的獲利模式
好那首先我們來看一下一個做空的例子
那在昨天事務日的時候
夜晚直播的時候
盤面快速的下跌
我們在5分K找到了一個什麼OB
上漲後的強力下跌
並在三連跌中拉出中間沒有引線響眼的位置我們俗稱的FBG好那這時候呢我們看到了什麼價格快速下跌的時候藍色是快線穿著慢線做了一個什麼
死亡交叉
而價格快速下跌的時候
如果你是打順勢追單的話
小倉進場
穩健的話我們要等待什麼
回踩看有沒有機會回補FBG
好的確價格在這裡
做了一個回補的時候
同時我們搭配什麼
菲波納七好不好
高點低點拉出來
0.5價格再次被拒絕
打出第二浪的時候
選擇在FBG的下一根K線去進場
那止損呢
你可以守在FBG的中線或是上緣
那我們這次選擇守中線
止盈呢
我會打前方流動性的拐點
好不好 流動性的拐點
好 那大家可以看一下
這一張我們用MACD找到
快速派發的一個趨勢
然後呢
訂單快跟FBG等待回補的時候
我們選擇一個位置去進場
那進場後大家可以發現
這一張單我們就是順著
看空的方向打下來
下跌後的回調不過0.5延續下跌
而且回補FBG我們可以快速的達到什麼
下方流動性的位置
那這一張就是一個MACD抓到爆發點
搭配OB加FBG的一個回補進場的方式
那我們來看一個做多的例子
價格下跌後強力上漲
上漲後我們拉出了一個什麼
看漲的訂單塊下方是OB
而三連漲5分K我們拉出了
FBG中間的一個缺口
好當價格快速拉漲的情況下
好我們保守一點就等待什麼
二次確認的回踩
好那這裡一樣嘛
綠色亮能柱突然放大
而且快線再次穿出慢線
實現了一個金差
好那當然我們確認的行情爆發段後
我們要等待二次確認的回踩
好那價格運行過來後
價格碰到了這裡有反例
好我們觀察一下
這裡重新穿上去
而且綠色亮能柱往上出來了
好那這時候呢
當他再把第一浪甩上去的時候
我們可以考慮進場一張多單
好當價格做第一個結構改變拉出第二浪後我們可以在這裡去進一個多單回踩後去進一個多單止損守這裡 知音我會打前高好不好 打前高那價格就很快速的往上打
而做到了什麼
一張很不錯隱窺筆的一個單子
所以當我們找到了看漲訂單塊
拉出了一個失衡區
價格重新運行回來後
就是我們準備進場的機會
同時搭配什麼
快線穿了慢線
做一個黃金交叉
而綠色的亮能度放大
做了第一層的結構改變
有機會有效的回補訂單後
價格要延續上漲
那做止盈前稿是最穩的
那就可以收獲這一張很不錯的一個單子
好 那更多的實盤應用啊
我會放在我的直播間以及群組裡
如果你還沒有加到我們
短期的交易大中華第一交易群組的夥伴
記得填寫表單私訊我
透過各種短期的策略
來讓你的倉位快速的翻倍
MACD是爆發的提醒器
行情準備派上去的時候
搭配黃金交叉
去找到回補的一個進彩點
但不要單獨用來進場
那MACD加FVG是動能加結構的組合拳
他的勝率在短線裡面會非常高
那如果突破沒有FVG的時候
我們不建議直接追
因為很有可能他沒有回彩後
直接沒有守住
直接畫門往下灌
做了一個假突破的一個又多行情
那很容易指引就變了止損
那MACD我們用來判斷動能
而FVG幫你控什麼
風險
因為二次確認的回菜做延續突破結構
才是在短線交易更完整的策略
如果你常常做過行情的爆發點
記得學會我們這一招
MACD加FBG的什麼
斷線爆發策略
啟動加定位一步到尾
如果覺得這一集有幫助
記得幫我留言
MACD我上車了
下一集我們會講
其他指標搭配1分K的短線組合拳
那教你看懂暴風雨前的寧靜
提早埋伏行情
跟著直播間和群組
快速的把我們倉位安全的翻倍
用體驗金開打5本翻艙
完全不會有壓力
記得用你發財的小手訂閱我
開啟小鈴鐺
我們下集見